[Music]
when I put the key in the ignition and
turned it it wouldn't start
the car that I was driving at the time
was a beat-up old Toyota station wagon
from the early 90s and it wasn't very
reliable
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd been driving all night and I was
just so tired and I remember wanting to
stop and go to the bathroom maybe get a
cup of coffee or whatever and anywhere
he looked there was just nothing
and I finally saw a sign that said
Samuel dinsmoor's cabin home or some
I went up to the visitor center and
asked what the deal was and they said
that you know you could take a tour so I
thought well maybe this will kill the
monotony a little bit so I went ahead
and paid the fifteen dollars or whatever
[Applause]
we went into the house and everything
was amazing I mean it was pretty
striking how immaculate the floors were
in the furniture and how everything had
been preserved exactly the way it
probably was a hundred years ago and
that was fascinating I remember at one
point wanting to lighten the mood a
little bit
the tour guide had made a reference to
Lincoln and I had heard this joke when I
was a little kid and so I raised my hand
and said you know who the least guilty
president is and he said I don't know
what and I said Lincoln because he was
in ascent like he was in a scent meaning
the one scent like a one he's in the
penny
you know Lincoln's face so he's in a
scent which also sounds like innocent
not guilty so that was that was the joke
and nobody really laughed at it and the
tour guide actually seemed a little bit
annoyed that I interrupted his tour and
so we were kind of at odds from that
point moving forward one of the ladies
who was also on the tour asked some of
the people around her something to the
effect of do you guys smell
I thought maybe you know that's just the
way old wood smells when it rots or
something like that I just thought it
was just generally stinky place you know
but a couple of the other people chimed
in and said that they smelled it too
well people started looking at their
shoes to see if they had something on it
and when I picked up my right shoe I
looked and I noticed that there was
on the shoe and I kind of
freaked out and then I picked up my
other shoe and the other one was even
worse like like my the rim of my pant
leg it was literally like as though I
was just waiting my feet in some giant
pool of or something like that and
while I was picking up my shoe that lady
pointed at me and she just went it's him
it's him like that and everybody was
looking at me and I turned around and
the entire spiral staircase that we had
walked up you could see footprints
and the tour guide was furious he was
yelling at the top of his lungs just
like you know who does that who walks
around and doesn't know they have dog
on their shoes or whatever
anyway he pulled out his phone and
started making that call and that's when
I knew that I was probably gonna be in
some kind of trouble for this without
hesitating I started going down the
spiral staircase went to the front door
and there was a lady standing there with
a clipboard and she was pointing at the
dog on the floor and she said do
you know who did this and I said no I
have no idea and I just brushed past her
and just went straight to my car
this part the details get a little bit
hazy but to the best of my knowledge I
remember putting the key into the
ignition and turning it and nothing
happened
[Music]
I knew that if she was able to reach me
she was going to get my name and address
and that they were gonna send me some
kind of a cleaning bill like the hotels
do and I don't have 250 dollars that I
can spend a clean up dog from some
guys house
I remember even getting kind of
religious at one point in just being
like please you know let this
car start you know and I just kept
turning it and turning it and I don't
know what happened if there was some
kind of intervention or what but finally
I turned the key and the car started and
I just I remember pulling out of the
driveway and going down the highway and
getting back on i-70 and I saw a sign
that said Colorado border 80 miles ahead
and that's the first time that I knew
that I was gonna be okay
[Music]